years can go by between the announcement
of a big Hollywood film project and its
actual arrival in theaters but sometimes
studios and distributors will shell the
finished film for years if they believe
it's in their best financial or
promotional interest here are a few
films that took years to appear on the
big screen Red Dawn turning to remakes
of popular films from its vault in the
late 2000s to help stave off financial
ruin MGM hired Dan Bradley to helm a
remake of the 1984 cold war film Red
Dawn it's about a ragtag group of
teenagers who mount a resistance against
invading Soviet Union forces I know
we're outnumbered and we're outgunned
that doesn't mean we can't make a
difference
the remake starring Chris Hemsworth and
set in the present day originally had
Chinese antagonists but to quell
controversy and increase the chances of
a Chinese release the villains were
changed to the North Koreans in
post-production
the updated Red Dawn was originally
scheduled for release in 2010 but was
shelved due to the studio's then pending
bankruptcy while it was in limbo the
filmmakers spent around 1 million
dollars in edits CGI and dubbing to
remove all things China from the film it
was finally released on November 23rd
2012 but never in China despite the work
done to make the film more China
friendly The Cabin in the Woods the
satirical horror gym The Cabin in the
Woods co-written and produced by Joss
Whedon is another Chris Hemsworth lead
film that was tangled up in MGM's
disastrous financial crisis in the late
2000s their ears are stopped well that's
how it works
originally scheduled for release on
February 5th 2010 the film didn't arrive
in theaters until more than two years
later after initially delaying the film
so they could convert it to 3d MGM
shelved the movie indefinitely after
succumbing to its financial woes instead
of pushing forward with a new
distribution strategy newly appointed
executives chose to sell the movie along
with Red Dawn to Lionsgate in 2011 and
it finally made its debut on April 13
2012 repo men based on the novel
repossession Mambo by Eric Garcia
2010's repo man stars Jude Law and
Forest Whitaker as agents for a company
called the Union
that sells biomechanical organs when the
company's customers fail to pay their
due the Union sends agents to repossess
the goods nothing for violence bish
the film inter production in 2007 two
years prior to Garcia's novel being
published and finished filming the
following year however since another
film with a very similar title and
premise repo the Genetic Opera was also
in the pipeline Universal chose this
shelf the film to avoid competition not
releasing it for another two years
House of a thousand Corpses Rob Zombie's
cult a horror classic house of a
thousand Corpses took a long and arduous
road to theatres originally filmed in
2000 the movie followed the Firefly
family as they traveled across the
country on Halloween killing and maiming
along the way due to the amount of blood
gore and violence the film received an
nc-17 rating by the MPAA forcing
universal to deem the film a bad
investment and shelve it indefinitely
several months later zombie purchased
the rights from Universal and began
searching for another distributor with
MGM eventually picking up the film and
scheduling it for release in October
2002 however MGM later dropped the
project after zombie reportedly joked
that the studio had no morals since they
chose to distribute it Lionsgate
ultimately released a toned-down r-rated
cut of the flick on April 11 2003 take
me home tonight
the 2011 retro comedy take me home
tonight arguably came closer than most
films at capturing the essence of the
80s but that's one of the few positive
things critics had to say about the film
set in Los Angeles in 1988 the comedy
follows Topher Grace is Matt Franklin as
he pursues his high school crush and
reconnects with old friends over the
course of one wild night what do you do
anyway tell you one time i tee i work at
Suncoast video since the movie featured
heavy use of cocaine as part of the
night crazy high jinks Universal didn't
know how to go about marketing it which
led to the studio indefinitely shelving
the film until rogue acquired the
distribution rights for 10 million
dollars
take me home tonight finally debuted on
March 4th 2011 four years after it
finished filming Wow
congratulations thanks for watching
click the looper icon to subscribe to
our YouTube channel let's check out all
this cool stuff we know you'll love to
[Music]